[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back off the record
where we talk about what let me tell you
something that just went down today I
was picking up these cafe said ass thank
you mommy's right people all right so I
go up II but what people think of evil
no no no he was one of the Asians right
oh so this [ __ ]
geez get masks on like this right I see
so many people like that yeah he was in
the store he was like yeah he was like
no he was in the store right he was he
was by the window and I don't know what
he was looking at but he was talking to
the window and he was like on a serious
business call
you know I taught him bring not fault
three what's the point it on a second
mask I don't remember the beard but I
just remember looking at him like what's
the [ __ ] point cuz the sound can
still go through yeah you don't have to
talk with this opened and you're inside
of the restaurant so what does he do
like when he's inside the restaurant he
goes off thank God like it's a hat like
for manners right I didn't when he goes
back out does he put it back on like I
don't know I was just watching the dude
thank God that wasn't a racist white guy
in there I remember when this party
going there in the first place
cookies race cuz he wants to be me angry
I wanna ban mace he's racist but he
really likes colonies what we didn't say
oh yeah this thing first happened in
like when I was breaking out in China
and everybody's already wearing a mask
in China but the weird part was when
they went into a restaurant everybody
took off their masks well that's a
moment dude though cuz how do you eat
with it was just like a normal thing
that was just like everybody would take
it off as soon as they walk through the
doors
they have food in front of them is just
oh I'm inside the restaurant yeah as if
this was like a different world where
everything was safe do you think it
comes loose airborne yes that's why
that's why they started enforcing [ __ ]
and you can't go anymore
did you guys see the video that went
viral so it's um this guy that works at
a gas station and he like or dresses the
camera already and he's like alright
this like this lady's freaking crazy so
she walks in and she has her mask on and
she cuts no hole out here he's like man
where did you get this mass or something
like that and then she's like oh yeah
you know actually I cut the hole myself
because it makes it really hard to
breathe he goes alright I'll make sure
to you know look those up pointless I
went to a Chinese takeout place uh last
week and it was after filming this but a
couple weeks ago I was after filming
this and then I
I got there and then I realized I didn't
have my mask on me and it's extra like I
feel like if you go to the Asian places
people are extra careful compared to
like going to some white places people
else is like that extra lenient to at
the same time against the only Asian I
think they do they do no okay there's a
stereotype or like you came from Wuhan
so I think they're extra careful of that
that regard what is another regard right
there guarding the reputation like that
kind of like that like always we started
this [ __ ] you know there's the other
side where I think a lot of Asians they
have the [ __ ] mentality where there's
like like [ __ ] scratch that ass
smells like the whole boy with the
[ __ ] mask on his chin coughing and
[ __ ] so I think I do think like when you
come in hey where's your mask if you
don't have it Delight who care
well I always do prepared they served
you know the place was super crowded at
the time too so I was like oh [ __ ] what
I do is however I was just pacing out in
the front going like what do I do
well I mean eventually I was waiting for
the order anyways it was so crowded I
was like what do i do so eventually i
wayan like that and i stood in there
waiting for and then i reached our
pocket and I remember Joe gave me some
random mask and I found this randomly
slowly put it on I don't even remember
giving you a mass no one noticed we have
a box full of masks here just in case
anyone needs to I know the message you
gave us for that first shoot and the
gloves I saved him I have in my family
nightstand just in case I do have a lot
of other mess so like the reusable kind
of button I gave my car just in case I
went to the store and I forgot it I
don't go back home and I drove to is
like H Mart - so like oh my god like
that yes some papers won't let you in
without the mask
especially please they're like oh I
guess it's why you went yeah I was gonna
say like I feel like I got H Bart I felt
like they were taking you away serious
then it like Albert says oh yeah for
sure
hy I guess soon as you walk in they wipe
your cart they give you a mat or they
give you gloves I do like the UH
car wiping part yeah it's really nice
though yeah Asian market North Korean
service I haven't been not even I gotta
go to like Hong Kong supermarket or
Hawaii supermarket where there's flies
on the mingoes see if they care
I wonder what I think was like Vons and
they have somewhere at the front to wipe
your stuff down if you ask but you asked
on the like on the phone or something
they look at you like your dish was back
in them
oh you're wasting the time I'm like dude
the workers on the phone yeah Wow you
say no I did a security guard just like
waiting balls I could I get like one of
the things to wipe it he does I look to
me I love you sure they work there no no
random guy I think they work here well
if you see the guy on a polo shirt is
tucked in they probably worked there so
I always just ask people that's true if
they're wearing a red polo shirt and
it's tucked in and you're in target
that's your fault alright that's your
fault dressed like that at Target yeah
but no I workout Petsmart Hammer
it's happened to me before though where
I completely don't look like I work
there and then they they will walk up to
me and I'm like do I have like that no
it's cuz you're Mexican yeah I was like
yeah do I have like the look that I just
work here so because some stores have a
lot of like one ethnic group just
working there like remember when we were
at the slawsa and swap meet
so like the sloth
bought me is like all owned by a Koreans
and all the customers are black and
Mexican right so this indoor Swabia in
the hood yeah
so you kind of guess the Klan tell every
single store me and Bart were just like
browsing and all the freaking customers
would ask us questions like we owned the
store like the what y'all got like yo
how much this cost just take it do you
know that today is supposed to be the
end of the essential like not nothing
tomorrow right wait is it tomorrow oh
yeah okay for what none of the what they
just extended it all the time I guess no
no no no they yesterday the mayor was
like saying it's not till July or
whatever oh I think that's what I saw
like the stay-at-home order stand the
homeowner is all the way into August my
rep yeah I think this morning though I'm
not this one cuz that rumor I guess the
mayor came out and he was saying like a
lot of things are gonna start opening up
but it's a gradual thing it's like Hayes
- yeah yeah yeah we're in like so he was
just like there's a lot of people that
are worried that up until for like three
more months we're gonna have to deal
with the same [ __ ] and he's like
dispelling all of the rumors yeah cuz I
could have sworn I got it from his
Instagram right after this should happen
I knew it does have a check mark though
his picture has a mask on it but I
follow him on Instagram and then I was
like I'm a follower of Riverside County
just to keep updated well just to see
which hikes open ups I really like
hiking and it's online forever so I can
you start to open I'm gonna start dry
river sinus or a hankie did you see that
they're opening up the beaches but you
can't play volleyball you can't be in a
crowd you could swim yeah you can run
but you got to have a mask on while
you're swimming ya know that's something
that's me
but this stupid one is like you can go
fishing but you can't bring a chair why
stay yeah you know
you can't suntan I think don't even do
fishing then that's their like okay you
can only fish until your legs get tired
then you got to leave see some kids it
keeps you there for a living and they
thought it I had there and then the
people that told me they've actually
gone to the beach they said what they
don't tell you is all the parking that's
usually a next to the beach you're not
allowed to park there
they tell you oh oh everyone else tell
me like you're Park get your you're
parking like at least four blocks away
like all the normal parking is gone so
you gotta just over to the beach then I
can see Bart standing in front of the
sign me like nobody tells me [ __ ] not to
a mess what I mean Nitori not even like
suggestion anyway yeah so before it's
like certain stores could be like no you
have to wear a mask to come in right so
that's up to their discretion but then
like before you can just say walk around
your neighborhood or do whatever without
a mask because it wasn't I thought it
for jogging or hiking you know you don't
have to wear masks you I think I still
highly suggested it oh I think yesterday
is it punishable is that what you're
asking but the mayor also put out if
you're gonna step out your house you
have to wear a mask because some states
are Beverly Hills was I think like a few
weeks back um they were making it
mandatory as soon as you leave your
property you must there are certain it
cited so the police can beat you up
hopefully everyone like opens up really
carefully you know be like this cuz I
listen to an interview with this barber
in Georgia you know they opened up their
their barber shops and he's taking
precaution where before you know they're
taking haircuts back to back to back now
they're only doing the one haircut like
an hour
hmm and then they have to sanitize in
between so they take half an hour in
between haircuts to sanitize the custom
ones here been sanitized again so they
only let in like two people at a time
and then you can't even wait in there
your to wait in your car
too much and then to bring them in they
have to like tell them okay don't touch
anything we have t-rex arms we'll open
the door for you well make you wash your
hands and then your to get your hair cut
like that and then just so you don't
touch anything and it'll be really
careful but it's like everywhere you go
is that why the ladies were the gloves
all the way to their [ __ ] elbow yeah
but it's smart because right now the
numbers aren't like there yet in Georgia
or anyway right and then so he's saying
that as much as he wants the personal
freedom like they have to open up there
he's afraid that someone's gonna [ __ ] it
up right some other barbers gonna not
follow the rules and the numbers are
gonna spike and everybody's gonna have
to close it but you know what else is
cool about hair today's episode comes
from manscaped support for today's video
comes from manscape so manscape has the
right tools to get the job done quickly
safely and hygienic Lee Father's Day is
just around the corner and you probably
need a gift for a hairy dad make your
dad proud this year and get him and
yourself the manscape perfect package
you know what they say like father like
son so I'm a dad but I'm not fat hairy
yeah you are work counts yeah where's
the count I've seen we've all seen yeah
well I mean you guys know I've been
shaving my pubes but I do one thing what
one thing that you it that the
manscaping is actually really good for
not mine says dope is I cut my hair
yesterday clippers but there's some like
little straggler hairs that usually the
barber uses scissors and cuz you're your
typical Clippers are kind of like like
good for broad strokes but for trimming
they're not that good so I was like the
manscaped is good for trimming so I took
that and then I saved the the top part
and now she turned out pretty good it's
all my damn bikinis for your nuts only
and mask ape is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
they have forever changed the gaming the
grooming game with the perfect package
3.0 the perfect package 3.0 by manscape
is the number one recommended gift all
year long and the perfect package new
point okay it comes with
seneschal lawnmower 3.0 that's
waterproof has a cordless body trimmer
which is like it was able to clip it
like that that's nice and a ton of other
liquid formulations to round out your
manscaping routine this third-generation
trimmer features a cutting edge ceramic
blade to prevent manscaping accidents on
any part of the body chest hairy chest
or back look no further or even your
head and stop imagining your dad has it
covered because he probably doesn't cuz
are pretty nasty
so this 7000 rpm trimmer has helped
prevent manscaping accidents around the
world inside the perfect package also
find the manscape crop preserver a anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
that actually did use it once and I have
the driest balls ever nose awesome the
crop Reviver refreshing spray and the
anti chafing athletic boxer briefs
subscribe to the perfect package and get
a new replacement blade refill for your
lawn mower trimmer delivered to your
door every three months making sure your
trimmer always stays hygienic and claim
this is the perfect package for you and
your dad's perfect package for a limited
time subscribers get a free gift the
shed travel bag and it's $39 a lot value
value for all the females listening
you'll appreciate this part manscape
products are cruelty free guys care
about cruelty for you too yeah
paraben free dye free and did you know
that if you want to eat the clipper it's
vegan get 20% off and free shipping with
the code off the record at manscape comm
do yourself a favor and always use the
right tools for the job get twenty-five
twenty percent off and free shipping
with the coat off the record at manscape
comm that's 20% off with Free Shipping
at manscape comm used to call it off the
record
it's dadbod season time to get smooth
yeah yeah so we were talking about like
the barber and stuff right and like the
hygienic stuff so I have I have a
girlfriend she owns a hair salon and I
saw her post about this and she's
obviously like very upset that now like
it's been extended but she was saying
like it makes no sense she's homeless no
no she hasn't
but she is like not I mean just based
off of like what she's been writing and
like how she's expressed herself on
social media I'm like she's not taking
it very well I think you pretty much
like stuff a lot of people have like
physical brick and mortars like could we
feel that at the gym it's like you
siphon the top and then so now there's
no more money coming in right and then
it's like okay so what about not only no
option yeah what about the expenses and
then what about the staff or the staff
that have to feed their family what
about rent like what about all that
stuff I know exactly so she was saying
like what's absurd am different phases
that they're doing like that they're
opening it it doesn't make sense to have
like salons and people that are actually
trained in sterilization and like
decontamination to have them open up
later I was like that's true because
you're trained in there yeah because
they they have to disinfect like all of
their their stuff like yeah everyone has
that blue liquid bottle thing that you
stick your scissors it yeah they get
certified like they actually get
training for it and then they're just
seen as like non-essential and it's like
yeah so getting a haircut is an
essential and hygienic because I've seen
homeless people with a bird nests in
their beard and cause it's pretty cool
oh I think the Georgia the mayor or
something where she's totally ailing
like don't wat side don't get a haircut
and then she got caught getting a
haircut
very good but her response was hey like
I have to face the public I do so I need
to be presentable but she was like I
think
that I get but then she was like I also
care about my health
you [ __ ] yeah I'm chilling I care about
my health and I have to like keeping a
clean thing makes me feel pain although
you show that haircut yeah for women we
could go with [ __ ] years short hair
oh my god change hair cells longer than
Elson okay Wow is pretty sure yeah I
mean but she had a lot of room girl yeah
Oh tumor type she just like everyone
came out with a big beard and everything
yes because I think Barbara's can't cut
your beard that's one of the rules why
right now they definitely sick by your
mouth my mouth controls yeah
payment in general on there mr. sexy
yeah is that what you're trying to like
not [ __ ] bother people happening
there I'm too lazy no am I'm like I yeah
I mean the same reason right I couldn't
go to the barber so I'm like I'm just
gonna let it grow and then as I was
doing I was like hey my hair's always
been short I never seen it long so let
me just try that and then this was
growing out and I was like [ __ ] it I'm
alone for like two weeks straight let's
see what happens so yeah I'm just trying
something different
yeah we're doing that with take it to
you're gonna let him just grow his beard
out yeah I mean he's got the Mexican
genes you know he's gonna have a
mustache before me he already has a
mustache oh no no no do you look at him
it's like slightly dark up here I'm
always looking at him like what shaving
already no wait how did he 12 or yeah
like everywhere or just up here well if
he has like cuz his little like peach
buds peach fuzz started getting thicker
ya know so he was like then I gave him
the razor
no razor your razor or cases no a brand
new race okay no no no I buy the pack of
the guy's razors disposables yeah I
heard a lot of girls use guys
it's future better that's better yeah
why the ones they make it all click fat
and [ __ ] and I'm like what the [ __ ]
isn't that for the vagina yeah so you
shave you shave and then you feed
yourself oh you're trying to say cuz
it's like say what the [ __ ] yeah it so
you could shave it you don't Nick
yourself right yeah I thought it would
be
oh I thought your time up for the handle
a good idea shave it and then flip it
around and buy yourself a more the
better the best one is the razors that
vibrate I was gonna say some razors have
a vibrating yeah yeah that's for what is
it for some you never used the vibrating
one yeah there's a vibrating raise
supposed to be so that when you shave
your face is supposed to get closer like
ones are like they can have a few blades
on top no this one just shakes shakes
it's like it's like a vibrating
toothbrushes you don't want you when you
chicks go get like let's say you don't
get a nice alright and you get a
professional shave oh yeah because you
guys would never know the pleasures of
it cuz actually like I don't have hair
but when they lean you back and they put
the hot towel on it feels so good now I
have more to lose with the straight
razors down there I'm scared but they
can make a nice cut straight lasered
like here and in the side let me know
this the straight razor yeah feels good
I honestly would I'm gonna I'm gonna
laser my pubes I've been getting some
been growing ingrown hairs like from
shaving to my boobs ha
I've always wanted to try lacing my
kaminsky hurts tall man I mean how do
you talk about how do you talk like you
know cuz just from your guys's stories
it's like it's like it feels like a
rubberband is getting sad but what I was
gonna do it first and then you come back
and you think about it
you just being a [ __ ] wall so no girls
have higher pain tolerance I'm like if
it hurts for you guys for icing hard
even more but you know what I'm worried
about
I'm just yeah I've never wax down there
but I was like what's like my armpits
and stuff and I cannot imagine what it's
like down there yeah I waxed my legs and
you're the your leg skin is way more
taut than your vagina skin so like just
pulling that out I feel like fall that
hurts he's feeling though cuz I'm
worried about that i don't want my
nerves to die Woodleigh is the whole
point of lasering is so I could get a
lick better no you need the sensation on
your pubes no but the laser my birth is
like experimenting huh I'm not gonna get
on my yeah with the sensitivity on your
ballsack
oh well I don't think they'll do the
boss that really lazier ball like your
sperm sorry so dark there I feel like
it's lit more dangerous to know they're
gonna do your ball with your [ __ ]
because the way the laser works is that
he heats up a dark color really you know
that that is true because um there was a
friend that said that she couldn't get
laser cuz her skin was too dark yeah so
black people can't get it it's a it's a
it's not harder yeah but it might burn
your skin well I have to go and call one
of these places and ask the experts yeah
we should do it live all right
what is it ticklish can you imagine a
man holding their balls and then like it
hurts zapping it waters rather have a
man or woman woman I don't care I want
them to do a good job yeah I don't wanna
get lazier than the wrong places
[Music]
[Music]